wait this looks interesting
let's play this first
chess with no pieces
only Pawns
wow
I could try and play a London but I
don't have any London Bishop to develop
E4 has got to be a fine move
key two I mean the bong cloud in this
variant I think is a very like
reasonable opening
got the king involved
until lead Center game
I'd imagine perfect plays should lead to
a draw
okay I'm already feeling like pretty
good about this because I'm gonna have a
fourth tempo
I'll get the king in
that still is probably close to a draw
oh yeah C5 is coming
maybe a four
B6
maybe I should play B4 first
okay I'm trying to like just gain space
and then eventually put black and zugs
one
five is reasonable
oh E5 would be interesting takes takes
probably not good for me though
how about C5 here
or I'll see four here
with more time I could probably like
calculate a lot more but so far I'm
relying more on just intuition just kind
of General understanding
like trying to gain space
wow
A5
so if I take
I basically have two Tempe moves
what is black trying to do
please C5
and it might turn into a waiting game
but I mean
visually this looks
interesting
still feels like I'm
thinking for something more than just a
draw
let's actually play this first
I'm realizing there's this move though
okay
I guess King E3
E3 G5
I'm still not 100 sure what's going on
here
how about that final game between Ding
and nepo yeah it was crazy
all our games were crazy
okay so if after G4 then I have a
guaranteed defended pass pawn and that
will be winning
but we get into this waiting game
hmm
I think it's winning for white though
is what's end up what's gonna happen is
I'm gonna have a past Pawn on the king
side
like that pawn is going to be passed at
some point
after the trade of these Pawns
and then
as a bonus
yeah I'll just get the king to E4
this is uh
basically perpetual zigzong verbach
I'm not sure where the like final
mistake was but something went wrong at
some points
have you ever used a notes function on
the chess yeah sometimes I'll right
click and then click emoji and then
make some emojis
wait I have to be careful still if I
play this there's some D5
start with this
I think A3 is a useful move
right or this
here it takes
F5
I could take there first I just don't
want to give back any chances
okay
because yeah once the king moves back
then I take and then it's extra tempo
eventually can break through
so I'm curious
hey I kept my note
at what point did it go wrong for black
are you the engine is still useful here
engine says D5 wow
ed4 or G5
yeah C6 already like gave me a more
comfortable spot
yeah I guess A5 was maybe the point of
no return
and then the situation
worked out nicely